Speaker 1: I was actually surprised how many of
you wrote to me about this story in the few hours
before we started producing today's show, and I
want to talk about it because what's at issue is
something actually kind of subtle. The headlines
are Trump accuses the January 6th Committee of
seeking evidence of criminal activity, and a lot
of you wrote to me and said, How is how is that
an accusation? That's obviously the point. That's
what the Jan. six panel is supposed to be doing.
But what's that at issue here is that it is not
actually the job of Congress to seek information
about crimes if they find information about crimes
in doing their investigation. They should and can
turn it over to the Department of Justice. But
Trump's allegation is that that is actually the
prime motive for what they are doing. So there's
an Axios article that that sort of explains this.
Former Trump's legal former President Trump's
legal team accused the House Committee
investigating the Trump riots of seeking
to uncover evidence that would support a
criminal referral against him. Why it matters
The brief asked the Supreme Court to consider
Committee Chair Bennie Thompson's interview with
The Washington Post as part of its effort to block
the release of records to the committee last week.
Trump's lawyers asked them to block the release of
documents and records from his administration,
arguing that their release would undermine
certain presidential privileges. In an interview
published the same day, Thompson said the select
committee was examining Trump's actions on Jan.
six as it considers to recommend that the Justice
Department open a criminal investigation into
Trump. The select committee So Trump is arguing
the select committee is acting as an inquisitorial
tribunal seeking evidence of criminal activity,
and that doing so is quote outside of any of
Congress's legislative powers. The Washington
Post has confirmed what was already apparent. The
committee is indeed seeking any excuse to refer
a political rival for criminal charges, and
they are using the using this investigation
to do so. We're expecting a response from the
committee today. So again, if your reaction is,
of course, that's what they're doing, that's
the point. It's actually not the point of
Congress. The job of Congress is not to seek as
a primary objective information about crimes.
What we would imagine I spoke to one lawyer
this morning about it. What we would expect
the committee to say is we are investigating
what happened, who caused it. How could it
have been prevented? How can we make sure that
it doesn't happen again if in so investigating
those questions, we come across evidence of
criminality by Donald Trump or anybody else,
in our opinion, because remember, they are
not law enforcement. If, in their opinion,
there is evidence of criminality or at least
potential evidence to suggest an investigation,
they would go to the Department of Justice and
say, You might want to take a look at this,
and the DOJ would then make a decision as to
whether to open a formal investigation or not.
So there is some subtlety there, and obviously
there is room for interpretation and sort of
squishiness there. Meanwhile, the claim from Trump
is their only purpose. Their only goal is to find
crimes I may have committed or that they believe
that I committed. And that is not actually the
duty of a congressional committee and that that
is that is accurate. That would actually be true.
I think at the end of the day, it's
going to be very hard to make the case.
You sort of have to go to intent. And if you
want to prevent access or try to shut down
the committee or whatever else the case may
be, you really have to get into the intent
in someone's mind. Sort of like with perjury, did
you unknowingly lie or did you deliberately lie?
And it's going to be very difficult from what
I'm reading to successfully argue that the sole
purpose or the primary purpose or
the true purpose of the committee
is to find evidence of Trump's criminality. And I
think if you look at the genesis of the committee
in and of itself, it's pretty clear that while it
may be a bonus, it may be a tertiary or subsequent
priority to know whether Donald Trump committed
crimes. You're not going to be able to prove that
that's really the point of the investigation. It's
also relevant to say that in an abstract sense, it
is not the Legislature's function to investigate
crimes, but the Legislature has a clear function
in creating law and to create law. You need to
understand what took place and how what took place
relates to the existing law that's completely
legitimate. You need to determine does current law
cover what took place or not? This was an issue
with the. Remember this whole child porn case in
New York State, the details I don't remember,
but there was some technicality in how the law
used to be written, where viewing child porn and
possessing it were two different things based on
browser cache and some technical elements.
And after someone was acquitted or charges
were dropped on that technicality, I think
it was, the New York Legislature said. We've
got to rewrite how we define possession of child
porn. We're talking about something similar here,
and the House Committee can very legitimately,
from what I'm reading, say we have to understand
what took place in relation to the law because we
are charged with writing law. And if in so doing,
we come across the belief that laws were broken
by Trump or anyone else. We refer it to the
Department of Justice. I think they are. They are
ultimately going to have that argument prevail.
And again, strictly speaking, strictly
speaking, if you want to defend yourself
on process rather than on substance, which is
what Donald Trump is doing that is completely
legitimate in our legal system. It is completely
legitimate to get yourself acquitted because
the people investigating you did not use the
right processes. It's completely legitimate,
colloquially speaking. Donald Trump's continued
behavior is not the behavior of an innocent man.